[Music]
eat that space it's imperative nice
finish Chandler a second bucket and
here's Butler can't see the help coming
sometimes the anticipation for mr.
Butler and the steel those are his works
folks not mine he calls himself back
then exactly point guard and an
impressive slam dunk by Jimmy Butler and
here is Tobias Harris numbers simmons up
for Butler slams for two beautiful
basketball by Jonathan Simmons and
Butler on the fast break
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
second time we've seen Jimmy elevate and
absorb an awful lot of contact the ELISA
practically draped all over up strong
like Butler we're gonna tire going front
with a three bar we're bucking for Benjy
once and closer
beautifully done between those two and
one more at the line now the pelicans
and opportunity to perhaps win it here
is four for the lead and free no rebound
taken away by Harris and that's going to
do it the Sixers have gone and they win
it
Jimmy Butler was huge on that shot
attempt got a hand up he might have got
the piece then look at Jimmy Butler
right here I think he gets a piece of
that part
it was so off nearly ten seconds
separating the clocks it's Walker
once again blocked on the play by Butler
the Chandler what a play by Jimmy Butler
Jimmy Butler coming up huge for the
Sixers here on the guts of the game
moving his feet the block the city
that's how to control Butler backing in
backing in against Irving five to shoot
bust the ball picks it back up jump
shots are drills it with four point
seven rating though the Sixers go up by
five
Jimmy Butler can he win it here it is
Butler for the win buries the three with
three tenths of a second ago Wow
with these are looking tough you bring
it on hole with a big-time shot Jimmy
Butler with a game on the line
[Applause]
well you take a look at this again
you're down but you don't even need a
three nonetheless for good measure from
long distance dialing it up what up at
you boy Adam left coach you like that
content I know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from Bleacher
for